hey guys the question for today is what
supplements I recommend beyond just whey
protein and creatine which creatine
something pretty much everyone should be
taking and whey protein nothing that's
special about weight in and of itself
but helpful for meaning your protein
target if you can't or just don't want
to meet that with your normal diet see
ya beyond those things what supplements
would I recommend as far as performance
goes the two I'd recommend would be
caffeine and citrulline malate as far as
caffeine goes it's not going to be a
night and day difference but it does
there are several studies showing that
it acutely
enhances strength and power performance
and actually a recent study indicating
that even after you build up a tolerance
to it it may still acutely benefit
performance have some issues with that
study because that could have been
indicating not so much the caffeine
keeps helping your performance after you
build up a tolerance but that if
performance is tested without caffeine
it's actually armed it's hard to really
really tease out those two things yeah
caffeine pretty decent bet as far as the
dosage that's been found to be effective
some studies find positive effects with
doses as low as 3 milligrams per
kilogram but most of them find maximum
orgo Jinnah City at 5 to 6 milligrams
per kilogram so yeah caffeine citrulline
malate is a theorized to work as a
vasodilator so people used to take
arginine back in the day because
arginine can be converted to nitro socks
or a nitric oxide which is a phase of a
dilator but the thing about arginine
itself is most of the arginine when you
take it just as itself as a supplement
is going to be sequestered by the gut so
citrulline gets into your system better
and then
is converted to arginine then converted
to nitric oxide so there have been I
believe seven studies on citrulline
malate so far all of them dosed at eight
grams in our pre-workout if memory
serves and five of the seven have found
that it helps total training volume some
some one can handle generally those
studies are designed basically with a
set number of assets to failure they
find the people on the later sets can
keep performing more reps when they take
citrulline malate so a couple studies
have found that it makes no difference
several studies have found that it does
so so far the weight of the evidence is
in citrulline malate favor yeah
it's that's another pretty decent bed as
wealth as far as like non performance
supplements ago a couple I'd recommend
well not necessarily recommend but worth
looking into at least things that I take
one is magnesium magnesium deficiencies
are not that uncommon to begin with and
occur at a higher rate and athletes and
general population because you lose some
magnesium through your sweat so you know
that's probably something to get tested
for before you start taking and
definitely something to be aware of also
helps with general relaxation and sleep
quality so I just I just take it before
bed and if you do take magnesium make
sure you get a form with a pretty decent
bioavailability there it comes in comes
in several forms I think the one I take
is magnesium citrate
but yeah just look that up on I'd
recommend exam it calm for just general
information about all supplements period
but I know it has information about
bioavailability of different forms of
magnesium and pretty much anything a
couple others I take or
hope I'm pronouncing this right spear
spear Elena
it's a Algie reason I take that actually
is because it has been shown to aid in
breathing like rhinitis and I'm like
constantly congested so helps with that
I take rhodiola in ashwagandha rhodiola
is supposed to help with fatigue
ashwagandha with anxiety I don't think
I'm an incredibly fatigued or anxious
person and this could be entirely
placebo effect but I find that just kind
of subjectively I feel better when I
take them in the last one that I would
generally recommend is garlic you can
either just eat a lot of garlic which I
also do cuz garlic's delicious or you
can take it in supplement form it's been
shown to pretty substantially decrease
rates of contracting the common cold
which I think it's cool and it's a cheap
supplement like decreases rates of Colts
by like forty percent or so which is
pretty solid and then for female viewers
one one more to look into is vitex fruit
there's not a ton of research on it but
two or three studies have found that it
like pretty substantially reduces PMS
and minstrel symptoms so I mean I think
that is pretty pretty useful for a fair
amount of people especially people who
deal with kind of exceptionally bad PMS
and minstrel symptoms so it kind of
surprises me that that doesn't get more
press but definitely for the female
viewers something to look into there as
well for kind of all supplements stuff
number one resource I'd recommend is
examine calm they're absolutely
fantastic they have all of the research
ever published on basically every
supplement imaginable so yeah for any
any other related supplement questions
I'd strongly recommend them so yeah
that's about it for this video any other
questions you want answered put them in
the comments below and
hopefully I will make another video at
some point all right bye guys